ONE, COUNT 'EM ONE DEMOCRAT HAS
BOTHERED TO EVEN LOOK AT THE
MEMO.
JOINING US NOW, REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN SEAN DUFFY AND
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
YOU GUYS HAVE TO WORK FOR A
LIVING, WORKING FRIDAY NIGHTS,
JUST LIKE I AM.
YOU GUYS USED TO GO HOME ON THE
WEEKENDS, EVERYONE IN TOWN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
>> WE'RE PROBABLY WORKING
TOMORROW AND SUNDAY, YOU GET TO
GO HOME.
>> Laura: POOR BABY, SEAN.
YOU CUT ENOUGH WOOD IN WISCONSIN
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU SAW IN
THIS MEMO, I KNOW IT'S
CLASSIFIED.
DOES THAT SURPRISE YOU THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE SUCH A STUNNING
>> LAWYER, A I'M GOING TO JUMP
IN.
NOT ONLY HAVE I SEEN THIS MEMO
BUT AS A MEMBER OF THE INTEL
COMMITTEE YOU'VE BEEN INVOLVED
WE HEARD COLLUSION, COLLUSION,
COLLUSION.
THEN WE DIDN'T.
AND THEN WE HEARD OBSTRUCTION,
OBSTRUCTION, OBSTRUCTION, THEN
WE DIDN'T.
THE REASON BEING THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE FOR THAT.
BUT THIS IS WHAT WE DO KNOW, THE
HIRED FUSION GPS, HIRED A
FOREIGN AGENT WHO USED FOREIGN
ASSETS INCLUDING MORE LIKELY
RUSSIANS AND CREATED THE DOSSIER
THAT WE KNOW IS GARBAGE.
THE QUESTION NOW IS, DID THE FBI
USE THAT BEFORE THE FISA COURT
WERE THEY HON NEST HOW IT WAS
PRESENTED, DID THE FISA JUDGES,
WERE THEY PRUDENT IN THIS
MATERIAL.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF THE MEMO.
>> IF CAN I ADD ON TO THAT, THIS
DOESN'T SET THE DEMOCRATIC
NARRATIVE THAT DONALD TRUMP
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA.
IF IT DOESN'T FIT THE NARRATIVE
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE IT.
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING TO FIND THE
TRUTH.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR A PATHWAY TO
DESTROY DONALD TRUMP.
LISTEN, I DON'T THINK IT'S HELP
UNTIL FOR REPUBLICANS TO FROTH
AT THE MOUTH WITH WHAT'S IN THIS
DOCUMENT I WAS DEEPLY DISTURBED.
I THINK THERE IS SERIOUS ISSUES
AT THE TOP OF THE DOJ AND FBI.
WHY THEY DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE
THIS INFORMATION TO US, IT TOOK
US FOUR MONTHS, THREAT OF
CONGRESSIONAL ACTION TO GET THE
DOCUMENTATION.
ONCE I HAVE LOOKED AT IT I KNOW
WHY THEY DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE IT
TO US.
ALSO, I HAVE TO SAY, ALSO WE
HEARD SOME ONE MAY BE
PROSECUTED, I AGREE THAT CLAIM.
WE DON'T WANT THE DEMOCRAT
NARRATIVE, WE WANT THE TRUTH.
THE MOVEMENT TO EXPOSE THE MEMO
IS BEGANING STEAM.
I THINK FRANKLY THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE A VOTE.
THEY WILL RELEASE IT.
DONALD TRUMP WILL CLAP HIS HANDS
FALL OF 2016, I BELIEVE,
BASICALLY, HE LIKE POO POOED THE
IDEA OF ANY PLIT TIZATION OF
THE -- PO LIT IIZATION OF THE
INTEL COMMUNITY WORKING AGAINST
SIMILAR THING SAID BY SUSAN RICE
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL THAT,
WOULD HAVE HAD ACCESS OR
REQUESTED ACCESS TO THE
UNMASKING OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
BEEN SURVEILLED UNDER THE FISA
WARRANT, THAT WAS FILED AND
GRANTED.
THEY'RE SAYING, THIS IS A
REPUBLICAN PIPE DREAM, THAT YOU
GUYS, YOU KNOW, JUST DON'T WANT
TO ANSWER THE REAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS --
WITH ANY DEALINGS WITH TRUMP IN
RUSSIA.
>> THAT'S SILLINESS.
THIS INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN
GOING ON FOR MORE THAN A YEAR I
WAS IN MOSCOW JUST BEFORE THE
MESS WITH OUR ELECTION.
IT WAS CLEAR THAT WAS OUR
INTENTION.
THIS COMMIT, THIS INVESTIGATION,
HAS ASKED EVERY QUESTION, WE'VE
BUT THE FACTS ARE JUST THE
FACTS.
IT'S THE BOTTOM LINE, IF YOU
MADE THESE ACCUSATIONS AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE, YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER
THE ALTERNATIVE.
MAYBE THESE PEOPLE ARE INNOCENT.
BY THE WAY, THEY WEREN'T ACCUSED
OF STEALING BUBBLE GUM, THEY
WERE ACCUSED OF TREE SON.
TO BE FAIR TO THEM, YOU HAVE TO
SAY MAYBE THE ACCUSATIONTION WE
MADE AREN'T TRUE.
THEN, NOW, WHAT WE LOOK AT, YOU
HAVE TO BE HONEST AS WELL, THESE
RIN CREDIBLY TROUBLING
REVELATION
IT'S NOT JUST FBI AND DOJ.
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
POLITICIZING OF THE CIA THAT'S
THESE AS TROUBLING.
>> Laura: WELL, YOU KNOW, BOTH
OF YOU KNOW THIS WELL, BUT THERE
WERE A LOT OF WARNINGS ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN IF
TRUMP WAS ELECTED, GOING BACK TO
AUGUST OF 2016.
THIS THERE WAS A BIG PIECE IN
WERE SETTING HIM UP AT THE TIME,
THIS IS A FORMER INTEL OFFICER
WORKED FOR 25 YEARS IN THE INTEL
COMMUNITY WROTE THIS PIECE.
IT WAS BASICALLY A WARNING
PEOPLE WHO SAY INTEL IS NEVER
PLIPT SIZED HAVEN'T BEEN AROUND,
THEY -- POLITICIZED HAVEN'T BEEN
AROUND, HAVEN'T SEEN THE RECENT
HISTORY.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE OF FOX DID.
NOT GETTING ENOUGH ATTENTION,
FRANKLY, WITH NATALIA, THE
RUSSIAN LAWYER, AT THAT INFAMOUS
MEETING AT TRUMP TOWER THAT GOT
SO MUCH PUBLICITY, SHE ASKED A
QUESTION WHAT WAS THE MEETING
LIKE, WHAT WAS THE PURPOSE.
MEETING.
TRAIT MY MEETING WASN'T TIED
WAS AN AGENT HAVE THE KREMLIN.
>> I DID NOT COULD LEWD WITH
RUSH YAMPBLGTS THE PRESIDENT'S
SON-IN-LAW BARELY ATTENDED
ACCORDING TO HER ACCOUNT.
HE CAME AFTER THE START OF THE
MEETING AND LEFT BEFORE IT
IN THE EYE.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY SHE HAS NOT
BEEN CALLED TO TESTIFY,
QUESTIONS FROM THE MUELLER TEAM
YET.
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY, YOU DON'T
KNOW WHETHER TO BELIEVE HER OR
NOT BELIEVE HER, I WAS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE RUSSIAN IN THAT
TELL US WHAT YOU THOUGHT.
>> I DON'T SPEAK RUSSIAN, MAYBE
DO YOU, LAURA.
I WOULD SAY THAT'S CON RATING
THE DONALD TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I HAD -- EXONERATING THE DONALD
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT A
AND THE RUSSIANS, TRYING TO GIVE
DONALD TRUMP AN ESCAPE HATCH
SAYING THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
JUST THE WAY THEY'LL READ EVERY
DIFFERENT PIECE OF EVIDENCE.
CAN I MAKE ONE OTHER POINT, WE
GIVE INCREDIBLE POWERS TO THE
ESPECIALLY AFTER 9/11.
WE'RE OKAY GIVING THAT POWER AS
LONG AS THEY USE IT IN CERTAIN
GUARD RAILS.
THEY RESPECT PEOPLE'S FOURTH
AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
WHEN THEY STEP OUTSIDE THE
BOUNDARIES WITH WHICH WE SET UP
FOR THERM AND USE IT FOR
UP.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE MEMO
COME OUT.
THE ONLY WAY TO CHANGE THE WAY
THE FBI AND DOJ WORKS IS WHEN
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
THEN PARTISAN SHIP ISN'T THERE
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE THE
TRUTH AND THE FACTS AND SAY WE
HAVE TO CHANGE THIS.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN DUFFY, WE
LEARNED THAT THE PROCEDURAL VOTE
IN THE SENATE FAILED.
IT FAILED TO AVOID THE
GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN, WHERE WE
ARE THUS FAR, EVERY INDICATION
THAT'S THE DIRECTION IT WAS
GOING IN.
BUT WE HAVE DEFINITIVE WORD
THAT, INDEED THAT, PROCEDURAL
MOTION HAS FAILED MEANING WE'LL
NONESSENTIAL EMPLOYEES WILL NOT
BE PAID AT LEAST FOR THE TEAM
SO WE'LL KEEP TRACK OF THAT.
ONE THING I WANT TO DO FOR YOU
CONGRESSMAN STOOURT, HAVE YOU
HE SAID THIS ABOUT YOUR -- ALL
OF YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT THIS
MEMO.
HE SAID PROFOUNDLY MISLEADING
INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS MEANT ONLY TO GET
REPUBLICAN HOUSE MEMBERS A
DISTORTED VUL OF THE FBI.
THIS MAY HELP CARRY WHITE HOUSE
WATER BUT IT IS A KEEP
DISSERVICE TO THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS.
ADAM SCHIFF.
HE'S SAYING THAT YOU GUYS ARE
THE ONES MAKING IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
I GUESS THAT'S FOR YOU,
CONGRESSMAN STEWART SINCE
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY ISN'T ON THE
COMMITTEE.
MR. SCHIFF A FEW DAYS AGO.
BE CLEAR ABOUT ONE THING WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT DOJ OR FBI, WE AREN'T
TALKING ABOUT THE BODY, THEY'RE
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A FEW OF THE
VERY SENIOR OFFICIALS WITHIN THE
DOESN'T MEAN NO ONE IN THAT
ORGANIZATION IS ABOVE QUESTION.
THAT ONE OF THEM ARE BEYOND
REPROACH.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT.
WHEN THEY DO SOMETHING UNETHICAL
AND POTENTIALLY ILLEGAL,
VIOLATES THE TRUST OF THE
TO PURSUE THAT.
YOU CAN'T SAY, WELL YOU CAN'T
ATTACK THE FBI, YOU CAN'T ATTACK
MR. TRUMP, THAT'S THE THING THAT
I REACT TO MOST EMOTIONALLY.
IT'S JUST SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
IT'S JUST A DIVERSION THAT WE
SEE THINGS HERE, THAT TROUBLE
US.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN DUFFY
BEFORE WE LET YOU GO, I'LL ASK A
SIMPLE QUESTION.
ROD ROSENSTEIN IS THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL, HE WAS NAMED
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL BY JEFF
SESSIONS, JEFF SESSIONS RECUSES
HIMSELF FROM THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, ROSENSTEIN, IS
THE MAN IN THE HOT SEAT, PLAYING
HOT POTATO, I'M NOT DOING IT,
I'M GOING ON DO A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
IDIOTIC IDEA ON HIS PART, I'M
SORRY.
MY SOURCES TELL ME THAT HE IS
VULNERABLE IN THIS REPORT AND
CAN YOU TELL US ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT, CONGRESSMAN DUFFY?
HAS BEEN NOT COOPERATIVE.
HE'S ONE WHO'S HELPED STONE WALL
CONGRESS, TOOK US FOUR MONTHS TO
GET THESE DOCUMENTS.
I THINK IF YOU WANT TO CLEAR THE
FBI, IF YOU WANT TO CLEAR THE
DOJ BE TRANSPARENT, SHOW US THE
INFORMATION YOU HAVE.
>> Laura: RELEASE THE MEMO.
IF WE'RE GOING TO FULLY
INVESTIGATE WHAT THEY'VE DONE WE
NEED FAIR PARTNERS TO WORK WITH
US AND I DON'T THINK ROSENSTEIN
HAS BEEN THAT FAIR PARTNER.
>> Laura: IF HE'S NOT GIVING YOU
THE INFORMATION, WHY, WHY CAN'T
THE PEOPLE GET THIS INFORMATION
OUT THERE.
CLEAR THE AIR.
IF EVERYTHING IS FINE, IT'S
SEE IT, I THINK THE INTEL
COMMITTEE WILL VOTE ON IT AND
YOU WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO SEE IT
TENDING ON TWITTER.
>> NOW WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
SCHUMER SHUTDOWN TREND AS WELL.
>> Laura: WE'RE ALREADY DOING
THAT, COME, ON GIVE ME SOME
CREDIT, DUFFY.